we heard you are part of the friends
reunion special and rm i know you said
you learned
english in part by watching the show
rose chandler monica they were my
english teachers actually
from the states so so excited about this
who's your favorite character
uh actually maya was chandler of course
and actually it's really hard to pick
one you know
yeah i'm so excited to see you guys oh i
see the butter
everywhere oh tell me why this song is
called butter what can we expect
[Music]
yes sir and you can see the color of
butter on on his hair
perfect you're matching the vibe um you
know we
say smooth like butter will it will this
song have people moving smooth like
butter
smooth of course of course
[Music]
you are of course killing it how does it
feel for you
emotionally to break record after record
with your music
yeah he was so good so you are nominated
you are performing
at the billboard music awards what can
the army
expect as many people are expecting
we're gonna perform butter
um yeah so that's that's the most
important one
and maybe we couldn't we could
get the awards as many as possible
that's our
that's our wish can you tease any of the
dance moves for me give me one dance
move from butter
come on
smooth smooth
oh
all of the army is now going to dye
their hair like butter
oh what shirt watch your hair water
party
yeah harry pottery vodafore
dirty butter on my hair party
um i'm i'm sure you are excited to
perform and the fans so miss seeing you
what do you hope for for when you can
tour again
[Music]
my
that energy look we love dynamite is
butter
even better and bigger than dynamite
like you already said it's
already rhyming butter batter bigger
oh summer let's go butter i think will
get out of control i'm picturing
butter parties people are covering
themselves in butter
the cost of friends we want to ask you
about something else
exciting we heard you are part of the
friends
reunion special and rm i know you said
you learned english in part by watching
the show
how amazing is it to be part of this
reunion that's so true um
rose chandler monica they were my
english teachers
actually in the states so so excited
about this and for me it almost feels
like a dream to be
you know part of such a it's a legend
right so
now i feel like i i truly became friends
with with the friends did you get to
talk to them at all
ah because because of the virus
but but but maybe someday right who's
your favorite character
uh actually mine was chandler of course
and actually i i really it's really hard
to pick one you know
who's everyone's favorite character
well you know we love you the fans love
you and you
all are so amazing at being
proponents of standing up for people and
standing up for your fans you released a
statement condemning racism and violence
against asians what message do you want
to tell to your fans or how do you want
your fans to be able to help spread
awareness
another accolade for you you were on the
cover of rolling stone
and they called you the world's biggest
band
how does it feel to be on the cover of
rolling stone
as the world's biggest band
[Music]
is
different but just as cool you are
collaborating with mcdonald's
how did you choose what would be in your
mcdonald's meal
um actually you heard that um
the sweet chili sauce only exist in
korea
so this is one of the best sauce in
korea
um so i we thought that every
every people in the world a child sauce
and of course the nuggets has been
always our favorite
fries and coke classic it's not
mcdonald's without fries and coke and
nuggets everyone loves nuggets yes
of course of course uh and
fashionistas you are global ambassadors
for the iconic brand louis vuitton is
that a dream come
true
foreign
amazing well i know i i have to wrap
with you guys should i go
eat some butter and start dancing yeah
let's go
we already it's this is bad for your
diet though
you